ذات يوم لقمة ليوم واحد حول تغير
المناخ ، وهذا يعني أن
الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة مهم جدًا ألا يهتم بخطب سامية ،
بل مجرد مقترحات ملموسة
للعمل ، فرنسا وألمانيا والهند
وغيرها من الدول ملتزمة بزيادة استخدام
الطاقة المتجددة ، وهو معنى مهم جدًا
لملايين المتظاهرين  في جميع أنحاء العالم
تطالب الحكومة والشركات ببذل
المزيد من الوقت في مظاهراتهم
عشية هذه القمة ، أصبح الاجتماع
أكثر أهمية من خلال البيانات الجديدة التي تظهر
أن كوكب الأرض يزداد سخونة وأسرع
مما كان يعتقد سابقًا
مع السنوات الخمس من 2014 إلى
2019 الأكثر دفئًا على  تسجيل اجتماع
مهم جدا بالنسبة لنا  الرئيس
ظهر في الواقع لمدة 15 دقيقة مفاجأة
انتهت قبل أن
تحول الناشطة البيئية غريتا
بيرغ خطابًا عاطفيًا
يمزق قادة العالم لفشلهم
في تقاطع الجيل التالي
في بهو الأمم المتحدة
بعد ذلك بقليل ، بدا الرئيس مصمماً على ذلك.
لتجاهل المتدرب البالغ من العمر 16 عامًا ، بدت
مصممة على إبقائه منخفضًا ولم يكن لديها
نية للتراجع عن
انتقادها السابق لقادة مثل دونالد
ترامب ، فهذا كله خطأ ، لا ينبغي أن
أكون هنا ، يجب أن أعود إلى المدرسة
في  الجانب الآخر من المحيط ، لكنكم جميعًا
تأتي إلينا شبابًا على أمل
كيف تجرؤ على سرقة أحلامي في
طفولتي بكلماتك الفارغة ، ومع ذلك فأنا
من المحظوظين الذين
يعانون من
الناس يموتون ، حيث تنهار أنظمة بيئية بأكملها.
في بداية
الانقراض الجماعي وكل ما يمكنك التحدث
عنه هو المال والقصص الخيالية
للنمو الاقتصادي الأبدي كيف تجرؤ
[تصفيق]
لأكثر من 30 عامًا  لقد كان العلم
واضحًا تمامًا كيف تجرؤ على الاستمرار
في النظر بعيدًا والمجيء إلى هنا قائلاً
إنك تفعل ما يكفي عندما
لا تزال السياسات والحلول المطلوبة غير مرئية في أي مكان ،
فأنت تقول إنك تسمعنا
وأنك تفهم الإلحاح ولكن بغض النظر عن
الكيفية  أنا حزين وغاضب ، أنا لا أريد أن
أصدق ذلك لأنك إذا
فهمت الموقف حقًا وما زلت
تفشل في التصرف ، فستكون
شريرًا وأنني أرفض تصديق ذلك.